[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem samstag
die vom sport hat norbert mit viel
fußball guten abend die unterstützung
für die ukraine ist und bleibt groß
milliardenhilfe für geflüchtete eine
internationale geberkonferenz sammelt
spenden für die menschen in und aus der
ukraine
arbeitsverbot in russland internationale
menschenrechts verbände und deutsche
stiftungen müssen ihre russischen büros
schließen
und ministerpräsidentin dreier vor
untersuchungsausschuss wer hat bei der
flutkatastrophe im aartal versagt
tag 45 des krieges wieder mit angriffen
aber auch mit deutlichen signalen der
solidarität zehn milliarden euro hat die
geberkonferenz für ukraine flüchtlinge
zugesagt dringend nötige hilfe der
russische angriffskrieg hat laut un eine
der schlimmsten flüchtlings krisen aller
zeiten verursacht
innerhalb der ukraine sind 7,1 millionen
menschen auf der flucht dazu haben mehr
als vier millionen im ausland schutz
gesucht die meisten mehr als 2,5
millionen in polen und dort in der
hauptstadt warschau fand heute die
geberkonferenz statt jürgen kehl und
natalie steger berichten
zwischenstation warschau messegelände
nach wie vor kommen tausende geflüchtete
hier täglich an viele unsicher erschöpft
traurig
ich hoffe sehr dass dieses chaos dieser
schreckliche krieg so schnell wie
möglich vorbei ist und dass er wieder
zurück können
nicht nur in polen verschlingt die
flüchtlingshilfe viel geld eine
geberkonferenz soll helfen die not zu
lindern
die eu und kanada haben das treffen
organisiert der präsident der ukraine
ist zugeschaltet die demokratische welt
hat die macht zu helfen überzeugen sie
ihre politiker unterstützen sie die
ukraine unterstützen sie die freiheit
unterstützen sie die tapferkeit
aus der ganzen welt kommen am ende neun
milliarden euro zusammen plus eine
milliarde von der eu es ist ganz wichtig
dass wir auch geld
organisieren für diejenigen die
innerhalb der ukraine ihre heimat
verloren haben ihr haus verloren haben
zusammen gepumpt worden sind und
verzweifelt hilfe suchen seite hilfe
aber auch der symbolik nach von der
leyen gestern gaben sich der kanzler aus
österreich und der britische premier in
kiew heute die klinke in die hand sie
alle fordern auch klarheit wer für den
verheerenden raketenangriffe auf den
bahnhof von kartons gestern
verantwortlich ist 52 menschen starben
fünf kinder waren darunter das gepäck
der opfer stapelt sich in der halle
immer wieder meldet sich ein handy aus
einem der koffer
russland bleibt dabei die ukraine habe
die rakete selbst abgefeuert nur sie
würde diesen typ einsetzen westliche
militärexperten weisen diese darstellung
als eindeutig falsch zurück krieg der
waffen krieg der bilder krieg im netz
eine neue weltweite solidaritätskampagne
stellt sich an die seite der ukraine
menschen aus der ganzen welt rufen zu
spenden auf dabei sind auch weltstars
wie die singer songwriterin
billig
[Musik]
doch der krieg geht weiter befürchtet
wird eine neue russische offensive im
osten der ukraine auch in rackith die
zweitgrößte stadt des landes wird seit
über 40 tagen beschossen und belagert
jetzt droht den menschen laut noch
schlimmeres nach angaben des pentagon
bündelt moskau tausende soldaten in der
nähe der universitätsstadt der freie
journalist und kinzel ist im moment in
hartz iv hier sein bericht
das finanzamt in charkiw im krieg ist es
ein lebensmittellager die freiwilligen
helfer bereiten sich auf einen
gefährlichen einsatz vor sie wollen
essen und getränke in die stadtteile
bringen die unter beschuss sind
das ist für unsere sicherheit wir fahren
in den gefährlichsten bezirk unserer
stadt und da müssen wir an unsere
sicherheit denken
beim lebensmitteltransport können wir
mit fahren wir sind unterwegs in
richtung front die ist hier nur wenige
kilometer entfernt
wir erreichen ein wohngebiet ganz in der
nähe ist gerade eine rakete
eingeschlagen erzählt uns anastasia sie
ist froh über die lebensmittel
anfangs hatten wir noch vorräte so lange
wir strom hatten
jetzt haben wir seit fast zwei wochen
keinen strom mehr
die nächste station eine familie hat
schutz gesucht unter der erde lebt seit
wochen ihr wir sind hier in einem keller
eines
wohnhauses im norden von hf wir mussten
uns hierher zurückziehen weil der rauch
draußen die artillerie zugenommen hat
kira soll eigentlich bald eingeschult
werden doch jetzt ist krieg
vor leichtem beschuss habe ich schon
keine angst mehr
tiere kann schon unterscheiden zwischen
leichtem und schwerem beschuss draußen
sind explosionen zu hören
wir fahren weiter durch nazif eine stadt
im krieg
seit beginn dieses krieges versucht
russland noch rigoroser als zuvor
kritische stimmen im eigenen land zum
schweigen zu bringen wer von krieg
spricht wird bestraft unabhängiger
journalismus ist längst nicht mehr
möglich jetzt lässt der kreml auch 15
büros von internationalen organisationen
schließen darunter human rights watch
und etliche deutsche stiftungen carsten
behrendt
für die freiheit lautet das motto der
fdp-nahen friedrich-naumann-stiftung
diese freiheit sieht man im berliner
stiftungs büro nach dem aktuellen erlass
aus moskau noch stärker bedroht wir
haben schon in den letzten wochen
gemerkt dass der raum immer enger wird
dass es immer schwieriger wird in moskau
vernünftig zu arbeiten auch die
parteinahen stiftungen von cdu csu spd
grünen und linken hat die russische
regierung ausgeschlossen begründung
nicht näher definierte verstöße gegen
das russische recht ebenfalls betroffen
human rights watch gerade sehr aktiv bei
der aufklärung russischer
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine
es ist ein zeichen von schwäche denn
wenn die den mut hätten sich der kritik
zu stellen und damit auseinanderzusetzen
dann wäre das regime ja nicht so wie es
ist ist es also ein auto wie teer
geleitetes feiges regime seit jahren
beklagen menschenrechtsorganisationen
ein immer raueres klima hier eine
durchsuchung bei amnesty international
in moskau 2013 spätestens seit dem
verbot der größten russischen
organisation memorial im dezember 2021
sei die arbeit schwieriger geworden als
im kalten krieg zu sowjetzeiten
amnesty international wird sich die
arbeit nicht verbieten lassen wir wollen
jetzt umso mehr arbeiten und
sicherstellen dass die
menschenrechtsverletzungen durch die
russische regierung keine chance haben
und es werden wir von außerhalb
russlands tun müssen aber das können wir
auch kritik am russischen vorgehen kommt
auch aus dem deutschen aussenministerium
einmal mehr zeige die russische
regierung der welt ihr wahres gesicht
fragen wir unseren korrespondenten in
moskau gestorben warum jetzt diese
verbote
naja der russischen führung dürfte es im
prinzip im moment um zwei dinge gehen
das eine ist die isolation und das
andere ist das narrativ die isolation da
geht es darum brücken abzubrechen
kommunikationskanäle zu schließen und zu
vermeiden dass organisationen aus dem
ausland kommentieren was im inland oder
bei außenpolitischen aktivitäten
passiert und das narrativ naja das ist
auch klar seit dem beginn dieser hier so
genannten militärischen spezialoperation
will man natürlich die lesart und die
interpretation der vorgänge bei sich
behalten man möchte selbst die
geschichte dieses konfliktes schreiben
dankeschön für diese informationen live
aus moskau war dass axel sturm
hierzulande gab es auch heute wieder
demonstrationen gegen den krieg in der
ukraine in hamburg versammelten sich
mehr als 1000 menschen vor dem rathaus
zu einer friedlichen kundgebung die
demonstranten simulierten einen
sirenenalarm und legten sich dabei auf
den boden ihr protest richtet sich auch
gegen die gezielte ermordung von
zivilisten
auch deutschland hat der ukraine zur
unterstützung waffen geliefert jetzt
aber sagt verteidigungsministerin
lamprecht man sei mit den beständen der
bundeswehr an eine grenze gekommen
künftige lieferungen müssten zunehmend
direkt über die rüstungsindustrie
erfolgen lambrecht besucht derzeit
deutsche soldaten in mali dort läuft
seit rund neun jahren die gefährlichste
mission der bundeswehr und die momentan
wohl umstrittenste lamprecht traf
gestern in der hauptstadt bamako ein in
mali sind mehr als 1300 soldaten und
soldatinnen an verschiedenen missionen
beteiligt ende mai muss deutschland
entscheiden ob der einsatz weiter geht
nach mehreren militärputschen und dem
einsatz russischer söldner ist das
höchst fraglich
gescheiterte impfpflicht überlastete
krankenhäuser in deutschland wächst die
kritik an der korona politik der
bundesregierung der bundesverband der
kinder und jugendärzte rechnet im herbst
mit weiteren beschränkungen für kinder
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
zeigt sich dennoch optimistisch man sei
gut vorbereitet sagte er bei einer spd
veranstaltung allerdings hätte er sich
gewünscht dass die masken pflicht in
innenräumen weiterbestehen bleibe
auch nach neun monaten ist die schwere
flutkatastrophe im aartal nicht
aufgearbeitet weder die zerstörung vor
ort noch die frage nach der
verantwortung der geht ein
untersuchungsausschuss in rheinland
pfalz nach
zunächst ging es darum wetterwarnungen
oder die rolle des katastrophenschutzes
inzwischen darum ob die obersten
entscheidungsträger etwas versäumt haben
134 menschen kamen damals im ratsaal ums
leben christopher renze
ihre befragung dauert bis nach
mitternacht malu dreyer vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss im mainzer
landtag die ministerpräsidentin sagt aus
dass es am 14 juli 2021 bis zum späten
abend keinen hinweis gegeben habe dass
es zu einer nie dagewesenen
flutkatastrophe kommen sollte für uns
liegt die politische verantwortung darin
dass wir schlüsse ziehen daraus und das
bei solchen großlagen möglicherweise
auch noch mal geschaut werden muss wie
der katastrophenschutz in anderer form
auch noch unterstützt wird innenminister
roger lewentz als zeuge direkt vor
dreier geladen war am besagten abend in
der technischen einsatzleitung in
ahrweiler kurz nach 19 uhr für eine
halbe stunde dann fährt er nach hause
telefonisch informiert er malu dreyer
danach kommunizieren sie weiter per
textnachrichten ich höre dass der
höchststand hochwasser erst morgen
mittag erreicht ist ist ja wirklich
schlimm lebens um kurz vor ein uhr
nachts liebe mal die lage eskaliert es
gab wohl auch trauriges sehen morgens um
halb sechs ist die ministerpräsidentin
dann wieder erreichbar unangemessen
kritisiert die opposition
es gab keinen kümmerer jemand der sich
wirklich der lager angenommen hat und
anpacken griffin hat sondern wir haben
leider nur leute die sich weggeduckt
haben vor der verantwortung ob auf
landes- oder auf preise gewinnen die
flutkatastrophe mit 134 toten hunderten
verletzten und tausenden geschädigten
sei eine zäsur im land so malu dreyer
ihre aussage vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss wird wohl nicht
ihre letzte gewesen sein die
ministerpräsidentin soll noch ein
weiteres mal geladen werden
der schauspieler uwe bohm ist tot er
starb überraschend im alter von 60
jahren seine karriere begann als
teenager im nordsee ist nordsee später
war er in vielen krimis zu sehen als
bösewicht hofft neben fernsehen und kino
spielte uwe bogen über jahrzehnte
erfolgreich theater
auf die frauenfußball nationalmannschaft
ist verlass norbert sie hat ihre
beeindruckende erfolgsserie fortgesetzt
allerdings siebter sieg im siebten spiel
der wm-qualifikation das dfb-team
souveräner gruppen-erster 34 tore haben
die kickerinnen von trainerin martina
voss tecklenburg erzieht und nur 2
kassiert heute ein 13 0 gegen porto
bleiben die deutsche mannschaft in
bielefeld von beginn an spielbestimmend
tut sich im abschluss wie bei dieser
chance von tabea wasmuth zunächst aber
schwer erst nach einer ecke in der 40
minute trifft lena oberdorf zur
verdienten 1 zu 0 halbzeitführung
nach der pause geht schneller mit dem
toreschießen 55 minute julia gewinn auf
klara buhl 20
zehn minuten vor schluss sorgt felicitas
rauch für den 3 0-endstand
deutschland mit diesem sieg weiterhin
klar auf wm-kurs
knapper bayern sieg in der
fußball-bundesliga gegen augsburg durch
ein elfmeter tor von robert lewandowski
die bisherigen ergebnisse des 29
spieltags der fcb gegen den fca 1 zu 0
führt unterliegt gladbach nur zu zwei
köln schlägt mainz nach 0 2-rückstand
mit 3 zu 2 wolfsburg besiegt bielefeld
klar mit 14 0 das abendspiel härter
gegen union bereits gestern unterlag
stuttgart dortmund mit 0 2 am sonntag
dann noch drei spiele blick auf die
tabelle bayern weiter neun punkte vor
dortmund die verfolger leverkusen
leipzig freiburg und hoffenheim die
spielen wagen können klettert auf rang
sieben die zweite tabellenhälfte beginnt
mit mainz und unten stuttgart knapper
bielefeld und hertha abgeschlagen
schlusslicht führt
und das berlin derby ausführlich bei uns
zu sehen im aktuellen sportstudio um 23
uhr 30 zu gast bei jochen breyer der
neue dfb präsident bernd neuendorf
formel-1-pilot schale claire startet
morgen beim großen preis von australien
von der poleposition vor weltmeister max
verstappen sebastian vettel fährt nach
überstandener erkrankung sein erstes wm
rennen der saison es sind frustrierende
erster arbeitstage im dritten freien
training endet seine fahrt in der bande
die dauer der reparatur macht seine
teilnahme am vor lieferung zunächst
fraglich team kollege lance stroll
ermöglicht ihm durch diesen unfall mit
nicola latifi in teil eins des
qualifyings wertvoller reparaturzeit
sebastian vettel kommt noch zu einer
schnellen runde startplatz 18 mehr ist
nicht drin mit schumacher ist bester
haas pilot auf rang 15 scherle klären
ferrari zum zweiten mal in dieser saison
auf pole dahinter weltmeister max
förster
das was vom sport danke schön viel blech
sehr gut gelungen schnee im april mag
keine absolute seltenheit seien in
diesen mengen aber schon bis zu 10 cm
fielen über nacht auf der a6 bei
kaiserslautern steckten rund 500 lkw
fahrer bis zum vormittag fest vor allem
weil die räumdienste nicht durchkamen
zum schnee passen die temperaturen der
kommenden nacht es wird mehr dazu hat
gleich aus dem turn bettina schausten
begrüßt sie um viertel nach elf im
heute-journal wir alle wünschen ihnen
noch einen schönen samstagabend bis
morgen wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter der jetstream vollzieht derzeit
für sehr starke mehr under und
dementsprechend geht die luft weit in
den süden und weit in den norden und
immer wenn es so stark mehr anders zieht
die tiefs sehr langsam so wie dieses
tiefe auf dem atlantik zum beispiel das
hoch jedes erreicht uns dann in der
folgenden tagen und bringt wärme aber
noch bekommen wir die luft aus dem
nordwesten entlang des jetstreams und
das ist kalte luft so wird es in der
nacht dann in der mitte vor allem regnen
und in den bergen schneiden sowie an den
alpen und es wird eisig kalt die
temperaturen gehen zurück auf minus vier
grad nach osten hin eigentlich ganz im
norden und richtung oder neiße bleibt es
frostfrei und morgen im tagesverlauf mit
der kaltluft dann schauer und gewitter
die erneut richtung südosten ziehen oder
auch im süden teils regen und
graupelschauer nach westen und südwesten
eher sonniges wetter bei höchsten
temperaturen von 4 bis 13 grad ja und
die nächsten tage werden immer sonniger
und wärmer am montag bis 18 grad
dienstag bis 22 und mittwoch bis 23 grad
ein schöner abend